So what's down there at the deepest part of the sea?
Close your eyes.
Close them.
The ocean has five layers
Let's go
The first contains all the plant life and coral reefs
Somalia is not a good idea Jay
I know
Good luck Jay
Whatever memory you have of submersion is there
in the blue water.
Ok.
I'm in
I'm in too
The next layer is the twilight zone
All of the colours and light vanish
and the blackness you're in now
no-one can you reach down there
I don't want death Danny
Not in this place
I wanna be beside you
This is the other-world
in our world
That's not dust to dust, that's for sure
That's water to water
I'm going to remember this
You can open your eyes